YouTuber Aaron Maney otherwise known as  Mr who's the boss let me into a little  secret that he spends 100 hours  scripting one video and my mind was  blown I spent a lot of time on the  scripts and the other thing I do  actually is when I'm scripting I'm  thinking of three different people so  there's three people I know in my life  of different levels of I guess Tech  enthusiasm and so with every line I've  almost reached a stage where I'm  scanning it being like is this  interesting to all these three people  would they watch this would they watch  this would they watch this would they  understand this is this funny to them  when you do that you end up with a  script that is a little more broadly  appealing than it would otherwise be